[MUSICAL CHORD]
Hello, everyone.
Thanks for having me today.
It's a real honor to be
able to speak to you all.
My name is John Burn-Murdoch.
I'm going to be talking for
the next 40 minutes or so about
the lessons that I've learned
from visualizing the COVID-19
pandemic over--
well, I guess it's
now about 12 months.
So to set the scene,
what I want to do
is start off by talking
about the perspective I'm
coming from in this talk.
So data visualization
is obviously
an enormously broad church.
There's all sorts of
different uses for dataviz
in different settings.
But what I'm
talking about today,
specifically, is
data visualization
for a mass audience.
Now, as a visual
journalist, I'm always
dealing with a large
audience, to some extent.
The Financial Times
is behind a paywall,
so it's, perhaps, not the
largest audience of all.
But what's really
changed dramatically
over the last year,
working on the pandemic,
is that that audience
has become enormous.
It's become truly global.
And it was quite
obvious from as early
as the first couple of
weeks of March 2020 that I
was suddenly-- my
charts were suddenly
being seen by an
audience of millions
across the world instead of
just the tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands
who would typically see them
on the Financial Times website.
So the principles I'm going
to be talking about today,
and the best practices,
are all geared
towards communicating to
a hugely diverse audience
of people in terms of their
familiarity with charts.
I'm not saying that
what I recommend today
is going to be the case
if you're producing
a visual installation
for an art gallery
or a coffee-table-style
piece of work.
But really just thinking
about data visualization
fundamentally is an
act of communication,
and particularly of
mass communication.
So to start with something that
I suspect reads as incredibly
obvious but I think is actually
relatively little discussed
in the dataviz world, I'm
going to talk about the fact
that, to create really
effective, really
powerful charts, you
really need to understand
how people consume charts.
Now, to talk a
little bit about why
that's not as obvious
as you might think,
if you look online at the
numbers of tutorials there are
for making graphics, making
dataviz, whether it's in R,
Python, D3--
you name it-- generally,
they're focused on the technical
element of
constructing a chart--
what chart type to choose,
how to get your geometries,
your shape, space, and color
exactly right, how to do things
more efficiently,
optimizing interactivity--
that kind of thing.
There's relatively
little on thinking
about what more
qualitative elements
you can optimize to ensure
that people understand,
enjoy, and remember your chart.
And this is where I,
perhaps, get almost a bit
too corporate or
business-focused
in my view of this.
But when you're making
charts for a mass audience,
it serves you well, I
think, to think about them
almost as if you're
creating an advert.
There is decades of
research from people
who create billboard ads, for
example, on what you should
do in terms of messaging, in
terms of how you use text,
in terms of how you use
color and all of that
to elicit a specific
response in your audience.
And I think it's
that communication
way of thinking
that is relatively
underrepresented at the moment
in best-practice guidelines
for charts.
So as I say, when I've
been creating charts
that I'm hoping and
latterly expecting
are going to be seen by
an audience of millions,
I've really had to
focus on, first of all,
how do I ensure
they're clear enough
to reach and be
easily understood
by millions of people?
And then how do I make sure
that they stick in their memory,
and they're not just
post 79 out of 100 that
ping on their Twitter
feed every day?
So without any further ado-- and
I think quite fittingly, given
that I'm talking about lessons
I learned from the pandemic--
it's time to look
at the science.
So I'm going to show you
here some work that is not
my own work, but it's probably
the single-most-influential
dataviz research paper
that I've ever come across.
And it's one that I and
our wider team at the FT use
very frequently
and constantly have
in our mind when we're
thinking about how
to optimize our work
for understanding
by a mass audience.
And that is this
paper from a team
led by Michelle Borkin
in the US on what
it is-- what are
the characteristics
of visualizations
that lead people
to recognize the
story of that graphic
and then to recall it later on?
So the slide I'm going
to show you in a second
is looking at an eye-tracking
experiment from this paper.
And I'm going to show you a
GIF, so it's going to loop.
If you don't see it
first time, that's fine.
It'll come again.
But what it is is it's showing
where people's eyes actually
focus when they're given
a chart for a relatively
short period of time--
10 seconds, 30 seconds or so--
and asked, what do you see here?
What can you make out?
What's the main takeaway?
And so what you're going to
see is a simple illustration
of a chart and then a blue
dot on that chart showing
where people look when they're
presented with that chart.
And what you see
is, that blue dot
moves straight up to
the title of the chart,
has a little explore
of the title,
then comes down and
reads off the axis label
to see what units
the chart is showing,
and then reads across
the chart content itself.
I'll just let that play again.
So the eyes go to the title.
They then come down to
see the vertical axis.
And then they read across
the contents of the chart.
The key point here is that that
initial focus goes straight
to the title.
And the researchers did
additional follow-up analysis
of the same group of
participants and found that
when people, later on,
were asked to remember any
information about the chart
and just write a free-form
description of what they'd
seen, words featured very
prominently-- the title,
any annotations, labeling--
were all mentioned
far more often
when people remembered the chart
than the actual visual content
of the plot itself.
And that is something
we really center
on in our work at
the FT. Our view
is very much that you can
make a stunning chart.
You can have all
your geometry right.
It can be technically
executed perfectly.
But if the messaging--
if the text--
is absent, in the
worst-case scenario,
or too sterile, too
dry, you're going
to lose a hell of
a lot of people.
And the way I like
to think about that
is that your text can help
your chart be understandable,
enjoyable, and memorable
for someone who is,
quote unquote, "not
a chart person."
Those of us watching
or participating
in the conference
today, I'm sure,
consider ourselves chart
people, or data people,
to a greater or lesser extent.
And that means,
when we see a chart,
it's already a thing that we're
familiar with and that we like,
and that we have a sort
of way of understanding,
whereas there are millions and
millions and millions of people
out there--
a lot more non-chart people
than chart people, as it were--
who need that helping hand.
So to give you an
example from the pandemic
of this sort of way of
thinking and action,
I'm going to talk through
the origin story, as it were,
of our coronavirus
trajectory tracker--
so probably the
most high-profile
chart that we've put out
over the last 12 months.
And I'm going to start by
showing how this was sparked--
how this came about-- by
showing you an email I
got from one of my colleagues.
I think this was March
the 10th or 11th.
And so she's one of my
general news reporters
who was covering this
nascent pandemic back then,
or certainly the
nascent epidemic,
as far as the UK and
Europe was concerned.
And she just asked
me-- she's wondering
if I had any data on daily
cases in Italy, which,
of course, at the time, was
the focus of all the world's
attention.
There were grim pictures
coming out of there
in the news reports of bodies in
morgues and that kind of thing.
And she's asking me,
OK, do we have any data
on daily cases for Italy?
And can we compare that to the
UK, perhaps other countries
as well?
She hadn't managed to find
that data anywhere else.
And so I rustled up, that
same afternoon, or evening,
or whatever it was,
a quick version--
version naught point
O, as it were--
of what became our high-profile
trajectory trackers.
So you can see, for
those of you who
remember the final
version of this chart,
or they've
encountered by the way
of this chart, the geometry--
what is shown, what
is plotted here--
is essentially unchanged
from the final version.
We've got the number of
days since the country first
reached its 100th confirmed
case going horizontally.
And then you've
got a log scale--
a logarithmic y-axis--
of the total number--
cumulative number-- of confirmed
cases up to that point,
and a set of countries
shown on there
colored by things like their
global region or other aspects
that I'll come onto in a minute.
But obviously, if
I published that, I
doubt it would have cut through
to a huge audience the way
it ultimately did.
There's nothing here, really,
telling you what's going on.
There's a lot of
assumed knowledge.
Obviously, I sent
that to my colleague
in the context of
this email chain.
We both knew what we were
talking about and looking at.
But if I just put this-- if
we published this on the FT,
on social media, a
few people-- again,
chart people or
COVID-data people--
would have thought, oh, right.
Interesting.
But it wouldn't have
had any mass resonance.
So here's the next
version of this
when it's been styled, as
we style all our charts
on the Financial Times.
So we've got that trademark
salmon-pink background.
I'm now using the colors
from our main color palette.
Again, doing some sort of
semantic use of color there.
So I'm highlighting some Asian
countries in this light blue.
I've got South Korea
in a different blue,
because it wasn't clear
what trajectory it
was on by that point, and a
few other colors dotted around.
There's a bit more
text on the chart now.
We've got both axes labeled.
I've got that source and
footnote at the bottom as well.
But again, sure, in terms of
aesthetics, in terms of design,
this is now neater.
This is a better fit for what
we would publish on the FT.
But it's still missing
those crucial ingredients.
So here's the final
version that was published.
I think this was
on March the 12th--
so still about two
weeks before the UK,
for example, actually
went into lockdown.
And now we've got all of that
additional labeling added.
Again, going back
to that research,
these are the key
bits of information
that are going to be the first
thing that someone encountering
this chart focuses on.
And they're going to set the
scene for everything else
that they take away from it.
So we've got a title, a very
active title-- descriptive
narrative title-- that
most Western countries
are on the same
coronavirus trajectories.
Hong Kong and
Singapore, by contrast,
have managed to slow the spread.
So straightaway, you've got
a message which grabs you,
which brings you in, and
which tells you something
that is happening in the world.
The fact that
there's a chart here
as well is almost incidental.
Maybe I'm exaggerating there.
But the point is,
whether or not you
are someone who builds and works
with dataviz multiple times
a day or someone who last really
spent any time with charts when
you were age 16 and doing some
compulsory maths or science
education, whichever of
those groups you fall into,
the words here tell
you what's going on.
And so if you are
someone who doesn't
consider themselves
a chart person,
you've got your entry point.
You can now understand
the geometry of the chart.
You can work out what's
going on with the lines,
with the shape, with the space,
with the color because you
know what message
it's trying to tell.
If the chart simply
said "cumulative number
of cases by number of days
since 100th case" as the title,
that's a hell of a
lot more technical.
There's a lot more jargon.
And it's going to be much
less accessible to people who
are not familiar with charts.
The other thing we've
obviously got here
is these annotations towards
the right-hand side actually
explaining some of the stuff
you can see on the chart.
So this is more
geared towards someone
who has not been following
the pandemic and COVID data
in a huge amount of detail.
They immediately
have the queries
that they would have had
of this chart answered.
So they can see, oh, right.
So Japan-- its line
is further down.
The virus is spreading less
fast there and less widely.
But we can see that
it's not quite clear yet
whether the spread has
actually slowed in Japan,
or they're not doing
enough testing.
Korea, we can see, which
was, of course, the big focus
here as we were looking for
how countries could get off
that steep curve and flatten.
We've got an explanation
there about how
it has slowed its spread
from the initial pace.
And you can also look at
Singapore and Hong Kong
and see what they've done right.
So that text, when we looked
at what people were talking
about around the context of
this graphic on social media
and on the Financial
Times website--
that text was the
key part that really
seemed to cut through and cause
people to keep coming back
to this chart and,
indeed, to share
this chart with other people.
So the first lesson of the
pandemic, for me, I think,
was that using text and
other annotation is really
critical for making
sure a chart goes
from being a chart
for dataviz people,
shall we say, to a
chart that is truly
accessible to a really
mass audience of people
who haven't been--
they're not involved in
charts and data every day.
And suddenly, this is
the democratization
of charts by using text to
make them more accessible.
The next lesson--
and this is, for me,
one of the most fundamental
lessons anyone can learn
in the process of
building dataviz--
is that there's a big difference
between making the smartest
version of a chart
you possibly can
and the clearest version of
a chart you possibly can.
As with everything,
there are obviously
exceptions where you can
do both of these things.
But during the
pandemic, I think there
have been several examples
of how these really do--
these really are in tension with
one another a lot of the time.
So sometimes-- and
this was more the case,
I think, in the earlier
part of my career.
But it's still a
recurring theme.
And I think this is something
that a lot of people
here today will
recognize as well.
Sometimes we can
get into the habit
of thinking that effective
data visualization is
about optimizing for
precision and objectivity.
There's a list of
technical tasks.
And if you nail
every one of them,
you'll make the perfect chart.
You're using maths and geometry
to arrive at the best solution.
It's a very technical,
structured process.
But then I actually
publish a chart,
and it suddenly becomes very
clear that that is simply
not the case.
That is a convenient
but very rarely true
description of what we
should be aiming for when
we make a data visualization.
So I'm going to come
back to this same chart
and talk through all of
the clever technical things
that I thought I was doing
with this chart when I made it,
and then how the chart, then--
when the chart encountered
reality, shall we say,
a lot of my assumptions
were turned on their head.
So the first difference-- and
I'm just going to flip back
between these two charts--
this is the one that
I've shown you already.
This was the data plotted
on a logarithmic y-axis.
The point of this
was to say, well,
we know that the pandemic,
especially in the early stage,
spreads exponentially.
So the shape of the
curves on this chart--
if we plotted it on a linear
axis, on a linear scale,
they would all be
arching upwards,
from gentle slopes
to steep slopes.
And to me, you're using
a lot of visual bandwidth
there just to show something
that we assume is the default--
that all of these
curves are going
to be getting steeper and
steeper in these early weeks.
So by going for a log
scale, you free up
more bandwidth, as it
were, in the reader's head.
And you allow them
to focus on what
matters, which is, you can now
do the key thing that readers,
at this stage, wanted
to do, which is
compare the trajectories
of different countries
on a straight line.
You can look at this
and say, OK, the virus
seems to be spreading
more quickly in Spain
than in France, and France, in
turn, more quickly than the UK.
You can also, because
it's a straight line,
forecast out ahead
and work out where
the rate of cases
in your country
is going to be a few days or
a week further down the line.
You can answer that
critical question
that we set out to answer
here, if we refer back
to my colleague's email,
which is how our country is
doing compared to Italy.
You can answer that
much more easily
with these straight
lines that are
easy to extrapolate than with
the curves, where it's harder
to work out exactly
where a line will
be at a certain point in time.
So my thinking here was
all framed around this idea
that, when someone is looking at
this chart, the whole framework
they're operating in
that determines what
their takeaway
message is, is about,
are these two countries or three
countries on the same course?
Or, how many days until
the country average,
then, is at a certain
level of cases
that I know means something?
And therefore, that they're
not thinking, well, how many
pixels represent 100 cases?
They're not worried about
what's going on in the y-axis.
They're looking for more
of an overarching message.
However, let's have a look
at some of the feedback that
started pouring into that.
And I will say, just
as a quick aside here,
for anyone who isn't in
the habit of publishing
their work on social media-- and
I know it's not for everyone,
and there are certainly some
suboptimal features of Twitter,
shall we say.
But it's an incredible
way to work out
what does and doesn't
work in a chart
and to gauge the reaction,
again, of both chart
people and non-chart
people very quickly.
So I was inundated with
messages around responding
to these charts for week
after week after week,
and continue to be this year.
But this was a snapshot of
some of the initial feedback
to that chart.
Now, obviously, loads of people
understood the log axis fine.
But any critical
feedback is always worth
paying attention to.
And the fact that the majority
of people got it doesn't negate
the fact that plenty
of people didn't.
So lots of people here
very confused by what's
going on in the y-axis.
Some of them, perhaps, know what
a log scale is but just thought
it wasn't clearly explained.
Others clearly are just baffled.
And that's not a reaction
you want with your chart.
However, my response to that was
not to just think, oh, right.
OK, back to the drawing board.
Start again.
It's got to be linear.
People aren't getting this.
My response was to
think, OK, I've got a--
I'm in an advantageous
position here,
that I'm on Twitter where
I'm presenting these charts.
And this is a space where I can
continue these conversations.
So what I did was I immediately
posted a long explanation--
well, not too long, but a
relatively thorough explanation
of exactly why
logarithmic y-axes
were well suited to visualizing
data that grows exponentially.
That got a very good response.
And we followed up
on that, at the FT,
by actually making a whole
video explainer which
talked about all
of the decisions
we were making when
we made these charts
and how to understand them.
And this seemed to work
really, really well
in terms of softening some
of that initial confusion
that some people
had to the chart.
And my favorite
thing about this is
that, what you get when you do
this kind of work, what you'll
see when you explain
things clearly
and have them in
the public domain,
whether it's Twitter, Facebook,
whatever, is your audience
will start helping you explain
this stuff to other people.
So what we started
to see, quite soon,
was these other people
jumping into the replies
to me, explaining to the
people who had been confused,
look, this is a log scale.
This is what they do.
Don't worry about it.
And I'm actually pointing
people to the video
where I explain this.
So instead of thinking, well,
I just published the chart.
I'm done.
I'm going to walk away--
by staying in that
conversation around the chart,
I was able to ensure that
as few people as possible
actually remained
confused and to really
try to improve understanding
of log scales full stop.
And just as a quick aside,
something I find quite amusing
when I look back at these
messages is that you'll see,
on the left-hand side there,
two of the people who had been
confused by the log scale--
well, one of them--
their account is now suspended.
And the other one-- their
account no longer exists.
So I like to think of that
as being a little example
that people who don't
understand log scales
have other failings
in life, shall we say,
that lead them to be
kicked off Twitter.
Anyway, back to the
important stuff.
All of this about log
scales and people,
perhaps, initially,
not understanding them
but gradually getting
their heads around them
brings me onto what, in
a huge sea of contenders,
is actually my favorite
chart of the pandemic.
And that is this.
What you're looking at here is
data from Google Trends, which,
for the unfamiliar,
is measuring how
much search interest on Google
there is for topics over time.
And what we see here
is, this is the numbers
of people, worldwide, searching
for "log scale" on Google.
And I've got that going back for
the last five years or so-- so
from late 2015
through to mid-2020.
And what you see
there is a big spike.
Searches for "log scale"
in that five-year period
reach their peak on around
the 22nd of March, 2020.
And coincidentally,
that was about a week
after we started
publishing these log scale
charts on the FT.
And the interest--
the numbers of people
looking at those charts--
had really ramped
up over that week.
So I don't think it's
unreasonable for me, and for us
at the FT, to think
that the proliferation
of log-scale charts and our
use of explainers around them
really did help actually educate
a hell of a lot of people
on what log scales are.
And I know that from other
anecdotal evidence as well.
I had school friends
who I'd not spoken to
for 15 years getting
in touch saying
they were explaining
my charts to their mom
and that kind of thing.
So it was a real demonstration
that, by sticking around
and actually explaining
what your chart is showing
to people, you can
really help people
become more visually literate.
So the lesson there--
yeah-- is that, if there
is confusion around a chart
that you've made, that's on you.
It's no good just saying,
oh, how do these people not
understand log scales?
You've got to do the work to
make sure that the people--
you've got to do the work to
make sure that your audience is
not left confused.
And the key point
here, for me, as well,
is doing this additional
explanation in situ--
doing this explanation
where the charts appeared.
It's not much use publishing
a chart over here and then,
a few days later, explaining how
it was meant to work over here.
You've got to try and do
that where your audience is
so that they are not going
to get lost along the way
and walk away
scratching their head.
But there's more.
The reaction to
these log scales were
not purely about the log
scales, or about the geometry,
about the space,
about the numbers.
When you look at some of these
other responses, a lot of them
were much more qualitative.
Or, they were quite personal.
In some cases, they
were even political.
So I'm sure I don't
need to explain
to everyone that the
pandemic, COVID has all
become quite politicized, quite
partisan, over the last year.
There are camps of
pro-maskers and anti-maskers,
pro-lockdown, anti-lockdown--
all of this stuff.
And it turns out that the
use of log scales in charts
is actually another
example of this.
So we had some people
saying that they
felt like the use of a log
scale was dampening the impact
of increased numbers of cases.
So a line went up and up and up.
It then started to gradually
flatten as the rate of increase
slowed, even if the numbers
were still going up.
So people felt like
we were diminishing--
we were downplaying the
impact of increased spread
as time went on, because those
lines were becoming flatter,
whereas if they were
linear, they'd have
been going straight upwards.
And yeah, people really
felt that we were, perhaps,
trying to make some kind
of political point here
and trying to suggest
that, in the UK,
for example, things weren't
as bad as they were.
So the clear takeaway
from that seems
to be that, quite apart
from people reacting
to the actual data and
geometry in your charts,
they're going to come in
with all sorts of baggage,
as it were, in terms of their
understandings and feelings
about the subject matter.
And there may be
decisions that you
made in the construction
of your charts
that you felt were
purely technical,
purely to do with dataviz.
But people are actually going
to read into that a lot more
than what you intended.
So generally, there seemed to be
two camps of people, roughly,
who would look at these charts.
There were people who, like
us, in this session today,
who would just look at these
numbers and think, all right.
Yeah, what's going on there?
And a very analytical way
of analyzing the chart.
But there was a huge number of
others who-- and I think this
goes back to my
first point, really,
as well, about the
use of text and how
people understand charts.
They would just take away a
single overarching message
from these charts.
And so they would
look at something
where the lines were
becoming a bit more gentle,
and they would
think, oh, this chart
is trying to say things aren't
actually that bad at all.
And so it's just a really
interesting demonstration
of how you need to
cater to those needs.
You don't want someone to
have a negative reaction
to your chart based on some
design choice that you made,
even if you hadn't realized what
impact it was going to have.
So yeah, this can lead people
to completely throw out
the baby with the bathwater.
They'll decide that
this chart is wrong,
it's worthless, it's
junk, because it
jars with their understanding
of the subject matter.
So this is the
next lesson for us,
which was that information
visualization, dataviz, is
about much more than
just pixels on a page,
and geometry, and shape,
and space, and color.
It's about the whole feeling
that something creates
and whether that
meshes with or jars
with someone's perceptions
of the topic at hand.
So we need to think about that
when we're producing a chart,
especially on a divisive or
sensitive topic like this,
and minimize the risk that
someone is going to react badly
because of some choices
that we've consciously
made in the geometry.
If someone's objecting
to the data itself,
that's their problem.
If someone was looking at
this chart and saying, oh,
why are you showing
COVID cases going up
when the pandemic is over?
Well, that would
be flat-out wrong
because COVID cases
were going up.
But if someone is objecting to
the use of a different scale,
for example, and
the tone, the feel
that that gives to your chart,
I think that's not unreasonable.
Their feelings are what
their feelings are,
and it's important for
us to consider that when
we're designing our charts.
So what we did in
the end of the FT
was we turned these
static graphics
that we'd been producing
every day with a log scale
into an interactive
piece where you can
choose between log or linear.
So anyone, then, complaining
about not understanding
or being misled by the use
of a log scale, for example,
could then flit between the
two-- toggle between the two--
on our page here.
And that's what many,
many, many people
have done over the
course of the last year.
The next point--
and this comes back
to what I was saying earlier
about the value of something
like social media or
whatever platform you're
publishing your charts on.
And I want to talk about how
you can gain an enormous amount
from thinking about
dataviz, again,
as a fundamental act of
communication, as a dialogue.
So instead of just throwing
your chart out there
and walking away,
with explosions
in the background, as
it were, stick around,
get into the conversation,
and see what you can learn
and what you can gain from those
conversations about the work
that you've done.
I just-- I think it's--
I feel so fortunate,
as it were, to have
had the number of interactions
I've had with people all
over the world, from
all walks of life,
all levels of data
and visual literacy,
about the charts that I've
built, because I have,
now, an enormous amount of
information on what people have
liked, what people
haven't liked,
what people have struggled
with, what people have been
challenged by but risen
to, what people have just
thrown their hands up
at and not liked at all.
And so getting into those
conversations, I think,
is absolutely critical,
whether you're
publishing this as a
journalist to a mass audience,
whether it's to colleagues
at your workplace--
wherever it is.
So to do that, one thing
we did very explicitly,
from quite early on
in our visual coverage
of the pandemic,
was we explicitly
solicited this kind of
feedback, because sure,
as I've shown you with
some of those responses
to the log scales,
the nature of Twitter
is that you will get feedback
whether you ask for it or not.
But I think, as
anyone who's thought
about this for any
amount of time knows,
the quality of feedback you will
get goes up through the roof--
or exponentially,
one might say--
when you actually ask for
that, because first of all,
there are a hell of
a lot of people--
the majority of people,
in fact, aren't just
going to randomly hit a
stranger with a load of thoughts
on the work that
they've just done.
A lot of people are
polite, or they're shy.
This is just not how
they work online.
Whereas, when you actively
go out there and say,
let us know what you
think about the stuff
that we've been doing here.
What do you think
of these charts?
Do they work?
Do they not?
Any other thoughts you have--
First of all, you're
opening the door.
You're telling these people
who are maybe more introverted
or just don't see
it as their place
to comment-- you're
telling them that, yeah, we
want to hear your thoughts.
But you're also, I think,
making that-- any criticism
you receive much more
likely to be constructive,
because people now know that
their criticism is going
to be acted upon,
and they're not just
shouting into the screen.
So we would explicitly ask
for feedback over email,
over Twitter direct
messages and the replies.
We actually ended up setting
up a completely separate inbox
just for people to talk
to us about these charts.
And this is just a snapshot
from one day in April.
And this was a full
screen of Gmail.
But this one day's messages
spanned more than one
full screen.
So I think we had
about 100 messages
in one day about this chart.
And I don't think people will
be able to read the text there.
But if I just talk
through the range of stuff
we were getting here,
we've got people
pointing us to data sources
that we didn't know about
before for countries
in the world
that we didn't previously
include in our charts.
We've got people
pointing out things
that they struggled
with or would like
us to change in our charts.
We've got people just thanking
us for doing these charts.
We've got people who,
maybe a bit less politely,
are just saying, I
didn't like this.
We've got people asking us
to include different charts.
We've got people coming
to us with story ideas.
An enormous range of
information that both as--
both in terms of how we
iterate on this dataviz
and how we just cover
the pandemic more broadly
were incredibly,
incredibly valuable.
And none of this information
would have come to us
if we hadn't set up this inbox,
if we hadn't asked people
to send these to us.
So the lesson there, I
think, is very clear,
which is that, if we want to
do the best that we can do,
as data visualization
practitioners,
both in terms of improving
the work that we do
through feedback and in terms
of just reaching-- effectively
reaching-- as many
people as possible,
and making them feel like
charts and dataviz are for them
and not just for data nerds,
continued communication
is absolutely critical.
So I might suggest,
for example, that you
might want to put a contact
email, or Twitter handle,
or whatever works best
for you on your chart
sometimes so that wherever
someone encounters
this piece of work
in the wild, they'll
know they can come to you, and
they can give you thoughts.
I just feel like
it's so invaluable.
And you will learn so much
about what does and doesn't work
and the shades of gray
in-between by doing this.
Whereas, I think there's
often a tendency for us,
in dataviz, to see our job
as just making a thing.
And then we put the thing out
there, and we forget about it.
But really, really,
if there's one thing
I can get to you from
today, it's, don't do that.
Stick around.
Enjoy the chat.
The next point-- big, big
learning curve for me--
and again, that
audience feedback
was absolutely
critical to this--
was the risk of trying
to be too clever,
trying to be too technical with
solutions to dataviz problems,
and essentially losing
people along the way
and losing trust along the way.
So the term "blinding with
science," I'm sure most of you
are familiar with.
But for those who
aren't, it's the idea
that you're telling
someone about something
in an overly complex
or technical way
so that regardless
of the result of what
you've done, they end up going
away scratching their head.
They're not quite sure--
because of the terminology,
because of the methodology,
they're not quite
sure what you've done.
And I think there's often a
risk with that in dataviz.
So the question that we had--
this was still back
in the spring--
was, could we improve the way
we drew the lines on our charts
so that instead of using
a simple seven-day rolling
average, as we had been doing,
we got slightly smoother lines?
But we also got lines where the
final data point on the chart
was a more faithful
reflection of the final data
point in real life, because, of
course, the problem when you're
doing a seven-day
average, whether you align
that seven-day average to
the right, to the middle,
or to the left, is,
it's never going
to be an especially-close
representation of the last data
point you have,
because it's being
influenced by the other six.
And so the issue
we were having is,
the numbers in our headlines,
in our news stories at the FT,
would always be referring
to that last data point--
the thing that
has just happened.
But our charts were referring
to the seven-day average,
which was, while
cases were going up,
always lower than that.
And so we would
have this tension
where the numbers on our
charts didn't quite reflect
the numbers in the news.
So what we decided
to do was look
at whether we could
optimize the way we actually
draw the lines on the chart
so that they're still smooth,
as you get with an average,
but they also actually
more faithfully reflect the
very latest data point you have.
So for those of you
who have only ever seen
seven-day average
chart of COVID data,
this is what the underlying
data actually looks like.
It's incredibly noisy.
You get these huge
peaks and troughs.
New daily cases will drop to
zero and then shoot up to 1,000
the next day, because the way
that this data is actually
collected and reported leads
to enormous differences
in the numbers you
get from day to day.
There's weekly cyclicality.
There's all sorts
of stuff going on.
So we definitely didn't want
the data to look like this.
Now, of course, the
last point of each line
here would reflect reality,
would reflect the last data
point we had.
But it's far too noisy.
We couldn't publish that.
So here's the
rolling-average method
we have been using-- much
clearer, much smoother.
You can see exactly
what's going on.
You get clear trends over time.
You can see here, for example,
that Italy had reached its peak
and started coming back down.
But the last data point
on each of these lines
didn't necessarily match
up with the last data
point that had been recorded.
So what we considered
was a smoothing spline.
So it keeps that
smoothness of the lines.
It's still relatively
easy to discern
what's going on in one country
and compare it to another.
But the last data
point is now, because
of how the splines
are calculated,
much closer to the last data
point that had been recorded.
And you can see that
in this next chart.
So we actually measured how
close to the final reported
data point was the last
data point of each line when
we used this method.
On the left-hand side, you've
got a simple rolling average.
On the right-hand side,
you've got the spline.
And you can see
that the data points
are much closer to the real
reported value on the right.
So we decided, let's
switch over to the spline.
And we did, again,
a long explainer
of why we'd done
this, setting out
that need to better represent
the most recent data
while keeping smoothness--
big explanation out in the
public for anyone to see.
And I then, again,
followed my own advice--
asked people, what
do they think?
And here's the kind
of responses we got.
And what you'll notice is
there were two quite clearly
different camps here.
On the left-- top left-- we've
got a couple of people saying,
splines--
much better.
Yeah, I'm very devoted to
splining myself, for example.
And the thing I should
point out immediately
about that is that these two
people, Peter and Micah-- and I
don't know if either of them are
actually watching along today--
are both data scientists
to some degree.
So I think anyone
who's heard of splines
felt very positive
about that as an idea.
But then we get some
different feedback.
In the upper right,
we've got someone
saying the rolling
average is much
easier for the average
person to understand.
And in the lower left, we've
got someone with a data science
background, but still saying
that the rolling average
probably makes more sense.
And then in the lower
left, we actually
have one of the epidemiologists
in the UK working
on the development of the
vaccines talking about how
this is for the general public.
The audience for this
work is a mass audience.
It's an audience with a very
mixed visual and data literacy,
and it's much easier for
people to get their head
around a seven-day
average than a spline.
So different people with
different personal contexts
had very different
views on this.
So the takeaway that we
had, again, from this
was that you have to prioritize
the ease of understanding.
You may have come up with
an incredibly technical,
nifty solutions
that, on the basis
of any sort of quantitative
tests, works better.
But if that is going to
confuse people along the way,
that is a problem.
And again, for me,
the fundamental goal
of my data visualizations
is communication
with a mass audience.
And I would rather have
clear communication,
as many people as
possible understanding,
remembering, and wanting to
share these charts than to have
something which is
5% more correct,
shall we say, but loses a
lot of people along the way.
The final lesson
that we've learned--
and just in the last couple
of weeks, I think, in our work
on the pandemic-- has been the
importance and just the way
that you can use animation
to tell a story much, much
more effectively than
telling that same story
in a static chart.
And so I've done a
couple bits of animation
over the last couple
of years which
have been especially effective.
And I think the lesson I've
really learned from this
is that the sense of tension
and of anticipation that you can
build up when you
do animation well
can produce a much, much
stronger response from people,
a much stronger reaction, than
doing exactly the same chart
as a static chart.
So I'm going to show you
two examples of that.
They're examples
that some of you
may have seen in
recent days, which
are where I wanted to make
the point that COVID really
is considerably worse, for
example, than a bad flu.
So here's the first chart.
And what we're looking at here--
again, this is a GIF.
It's an animation.
It's going to loop.
So if you miss it
the first time,
you'll see it the second time.
We're looking at the weekly rate
of people admitted into ICU--
so Intensive Care Units--
in England with flu in a typical
winter over the last few years,
and then contrasting
that with what
we've seen this year for COVID.
And you'll see, quite clearly,
that flu admissions in the past
were--
even when we thought
they were high--
so even when we had
what, at the time,
was seen as record-bad
flu winters,
those figures were
much, much lower
than what we've seen over
the last month or two
in England with COVID.
So this was really attempt
to put to bed this myth--
this idea-- that,
oh, COVID is just--
it's just flu rebranded.
It's just a new
version of what we'd
seen before-- and to
show that this really is
a completely different beast.
Now, some people would
come back to this
and say, well, we're just
testing a lot more for COVID
this year, so that's
why we see the numbers--
we see much higher numbers
than we usually would with flu.
But again, I had another
animated response
to that, which is to show
the total numbers of people
in ICU--
in intensive care-- in London--
London, UK-- for any reason,
and compare that, again,
from winter to winter.
So in a typical year, even
during a bad flu season,
the numbers of people in
intensive care in London
never go above about 750.
So again, this is whether
they're in there for flu,
whether they're in there for
a heart attack, for a stroke--
any of that.
But the numbers of
people in there for all
causes never really
go above about 750,
and are typically around 700,
whereas this year, they've
gone up above 1,200, and
in fact, in recent days,
have gone closer to
1,400-- so almost
double the number of people
in intensive care in London
this year than a usual year.
And unless there's been a sudden
surge in the numbers of people
falling down multiple
flights of stairs,
we can point to
the one thing that
is different about this
year, which is COVID.
But the point is,
for what I consider
to be a really important topic
here, which is correcting
relatively widely-held myths
that what we were seeing
this winter was nothing
out of the ordinary,
and therefore, we don't
need to be in lockdown,
we don't need any restrictions,
because this is just
like any other winter, you
gain an enormous amount
by producing this
as an animation.
It's a much more
engaging piece of work.
And this graphic
on Twitter alone
has now been seen by more
than 10 million people, which
is far--
more people have seen this
graphic than any other chart
that we produce at the FT
all year on social media.
And that, I think--
and in fact, it's not
just what I think.
A lot of the responses
on social media
have explicitly pointed to this.
The use of animation
was enormously--
was pivotal to that in terms
of how it grabs attention
more than a static chart,
in terms of how it builds
suspense, and in terms of
how you get that shock--
that surprise factor at the
end-- when you compare the two.
So the key point there being,
where it's suitable, animation
is an incredibly
powerful technique
to use to convey a message.
Now, I think it should
be used sparingly.
If you suddenly make everything
animated, it becomes--
it's like the old
days of '90s internet
where you've got
pop-ups everywhere.
Everything is too noisy.
It's hard to actually get
across your key point,
and everything gets drowned out.
But using animation
sparingly, I think,
is an incredibly
powerful technique.
So all of that is to say that
the last 12 months, I think,
have been an incredible crash
course for me and for our team
at the FT in terms
of really getting
to the fundamentals
of how people
do read charts, and therefore,
what we should be thinking
about when we make charts--
what we should be focusing on
and prioritizing.
And coming into this year,
I think my assumption--
and a lot of people
here, I'm sure--
the assumption would have been
that people read charts a bit
like this.
They get out their protractor,
their set square, their ruler,
and their compass.
And it's all about precision,
and people are really
focusing on individual pixels
and where different elements
are in your plot
when they're trying
to take away that message.
They're almost trying to
parse the data set back out
of your chart.
And so you, as the
practitioner, should really
be focusing on the most
high-fidelity, most clear
encoding of that
data as possible.
But the reality, I think, is
actually a bit more like this.
It's a bit more like people
going to a movie theater
and sitting back and watching.
They are coming to a
chart to see something,
to see some kind of story,
to see-- to get a message,
to take away something that is
playing out in front of them--
in some cases, literally,
with the animation,
but in other cases,
it's a line chart.
But it's a line chart
where they're not
focusing on tiny differences
between data points
on the chart.
They're focusing on, what
is this top-line message
in the title?
What's the takeaway here?
And what are the
other sweeping trends
that this chart is conveying?
They're not poring
over it trying
to extract the values from
every pixel on the page.
So to summarize, the key lessons
I think I've learned here--
and I think these are lessons
that I'm going to be using
for the rest of my career--
first of all, text is critical.
I know we're all in
the dataviz industry.
We make charts.
But if we don't get the
text right, none of the rest
really matters.
People will be lost.
They'll be confused.
It will all be a disaster.
The second point-- we have
to take responsibility.
If someone is confused about
our chart, that's our fault.
And the best thing we
can do to combat that
is to include explanations
in situ around where
that chart appears to make sure
that there's as little as can
be possible confusion.
On a similar note, we
need to be considering
what are people's beliefs,
feelings, emotions,
sentiments around
this subject matter,
and how could they color
their reaction to this chart?
How can we design this chart in
as neutral a way as possible,
in that sense, so that
at least if anyone
does have any issues
with that chart,
it's because they
don't like the data?
It's not because they feel
put off or hurt somehow
by the way we've actually
conveyed the information.
The next step--
and I think, again,
one of the most important--
don't just publish and vanish.
Stick around.
Get involved in
the conversation.
You will learn so much about
how people are understanding
your chart that
you can incorporate
into the next one you make.
And make sure that your
chart, above all else,
is easy to understand.
It doesn't matter
if you can fine-tune
it to make it 2%, 3%, 4%
more faithful to the data.
It doesn't even matter, I think,
as much as-- it doesn't matter
as much as we think it
does about optimizing
tiny little things about
how people understand
uncertainty, or ranges,
or confidence intervals,
for example.
The key thing is that
you focus on getting
across that core message and
getting it across accessibly.
And finally, we
should all be aware
that we have this incredibly
powerful tool with animation.
And there are plenty of charts
where we would unthinkingly
just produce a static chart.
But an animation can
have that much more--
I would say, in fact, orders
of magnitude more impact.
And I'm going to end with a call
to action in terms of things
that I would like us, as
the dataviz community,
to do differently, or do more,
or even do for the first time
as we go away from this, which
is that, first of all, as I
mentioned at the
very start, there's
a huge amount of
resources out there
on how to achieve particular
technical or visual effects
in a chart.
But there's not very
much on the general way
of framing your work and the
language you use around it
in order to achieve the
clearest-possible communication
of a message.
So what I'd love
to see, and what
I hope to participate in
myself, is putting out
more resources that can help
people think of and refine
this idea of dataviz as
communication more than dataviz
just as a technical
exercise of creating
the most objectively-good
chart possible.
And secondly, I'd
like us to be more--
to think about accessibility
in the broadest of senses
when we make our charts.
Because we love making
charts, and because we
know other people--
most people on this call,
I'm sure-- on this session--
love looking at
charts, it can be
very easy to get into
the trap of thinking,
oh, what's the coolest thing
I can do here that other chart
people will love?
How can I push the envelope?
How can I make this
chart especially exciting
and impressive to
people who like charts?
But that is the tiniest
tip of the iceberg.
And the rest of this enormous
thing beneath the surface
of the sea is non-chart people.
It's people who last
looked at charts when
they were age 16, 17, 18,
and then got the hell away
from them.
They're probably people who
try to even avoid spreadsheets.
But that is an enormous audience
of people who could love charts
if they just had charts
that spoke to that,
and charts that didn't
try to be too smart,
charts that didn't
condescend to them.
So the other thing
I'd love us all to do
is think more
about making charts
not that are graphics
for graphics editors,
as someone once said
to me, but charts that
are for your mom, your
dad, and everyone else
out there in the world.
So thank you very
much for bearing
with me through all of this.
And please do fire me
all your questions.
And I'd also encourage
you-- in the spirit of what
I've been saying here, do
send me a tweet, or an email,
or anything like that with
other questions you have,
if you don't get time for
them just now, because I'd
love to hear your thoughts
on all of this stuff.
[MUSICAL CHORD]